all right today's topic
uh we are going to be reacting to this
creator's content uh he uh
threatened to uh take down our stuff and
have uh strikes and violations against
us and so i'm like all right well
let's go to court and he said don't
react to any of my stuff so i was like
alright i'm going to react to your whole
channel
so so this is one of his older videos is
that darius m
yeah yeah yeah he likes to mess with the
copyright system and try to
misuse it this one is called destroy her
ego so you know it's gonna be good
listen like the video share the video
like the video share the video but don't
judge the video
[Laughter]
this segment is going to be about
knocking a woman off her pedestal
destroying her ego
a woman's ego is is huge for years her
whole life she's been told she's
attractive she looks good that
she must be humbled she must be brought
down to earth
this is not red pale blue but this is
just toxic pill yes
listen if someone has their head in the
clouds it's not your obligation or your
duty to bring them down
that's what petty people do where they
just approach a girl
and then she's like i ain't interested
and they were like well the [ __ ] you
didn't
right that's what you're talking about
that's like yo if a girl says not even
she's rude just walk away
why would you bring that kind of
headache into your life to start arguing
with somebody in the street
why would you go out of your way to say
something terrible to somebody just to
remind them like oh you're you're too
you think you're too good it
cares inviting that into your life is
inviting unnecessary drama if someone is
arrogant be it a man
or a woman the idea that you think it's
your job to lower their self-esteem
is wild to me you're a toxic person too
and you need to be humbled
you think it's your duty to manage
other people's self-esteem did i miss
something
now now i have to say i do agree
to not put anyone that's man
woman that's stars
youtubers that is yourself because
because when you say yeah knock off is
better
when you feel this your duty you're
putting yourself at the place of that
pistol that's the thing there's a lot of
people i had some discussion with some
people and they think like you know
that's the rip pill the the red pill is
hating on that's not what it is
that is a misconception of what it is
that that is not what the red pill is
about at all the red pill movement is
really a
response to the flaws and the things
that are
the the things that are lacking in the
equality
discussion that the womanism doesn't
doesn't attend
red pill is just being
not being disillusioned anymore about
the reality of the world now for some
people that can look different
you might see it that way they could see
it as you know you got to knock them
down
you got to go for 18 year olds because
someone turns 18 every single day like
that could be their truth they're not
disillusioned about 30 year old women
so it is subjective to some degree i got
four tips today
number one texting one day hey this is
this isn't going to work out
simply because every man she's dealt
with and been with
she's left them so when you tell her
this out of the blue
or uh just anytime she does something
foolish
that's a la manipulation well hold up
hold up hold up maybe maybe
if you tell her this every time she does
something foolish if you just
why would you constantly have to retell
this person that you're going to leave
at some point they're just not going to
believe you they're not going to believe
you
listen if someone's acting foolish and
you will
leave and if they ask you why you can
certainly tell them like hey you're
being extremely inappropriate at certain
times
or when we're in public you act a fool
that's not
that's not red pill like you're just
being honest with the person you know
what i don't get
i've broken up with most of the people
i've dated right i've never thought of
myself as red pill
and i certainly didn't do it to destroy
their ego i did it to preserve myself
see i was in a situation i didn't like
so i left
i didn't live thinking it's my
responsibility to teach her a lesson i'm
like no
this is not good for me so i'm going to
remove myself i don't think there's
anything wrong with what he's suggesting
you do
i think there's something wrong with the
reasons why even if you're not if you
even if you don't mean it
tell the hate it's not going to work out
good luck
even if even if you don't that's that is
the
that's the epiphany of toxic it's not
it's beta as hell
you're lying to ruin her ego like what
are you doing
if you guys think this is good advice
hey man god bless you but i'm part of
this
you're not supposed to say god bless you
he's supposed to say hey if you if you
think this is good advice
bless your heart the difference
number two give it and don't text her
back this destroys her ego
sleep with someone you don't like to
lower her self-esteem
imagine what kind of self-esteem you
have to have to think this is a healthy
way to live
and to disrespect yourself to sleep with
someone you don't respect
crazy bro it's wild her ego is attached
to her
when you her you take her soul you take
everything she has
everything of value is all invested in
her
so when you occur and you don't text and
call her back and
like a symp you're a synth for calling
her back after you slept
you know when there's a new word coming
out i don't remember when i said that
there's a new word coming out yeah and
people at some point gonna throw it
everywhere
like it's friends frank frank's red hot
that's what this is
see this is what i think i think this is
an extreme reaction
you know i feel like men have seen a lot
of entitlement from women and they've
seen a lot of issues in that regards and
all this power that's kind of being
shifted and they think the right
response is to go to the opposite end
and to be an extremist in that regards
right rather than finding a middle
ground where you respect and you assert
your boundaries
but you also don't need to be completely
an [ __ ] because what you end up
making
is women who are jaded on the other end
and so you just polarize the two extreme
ends it's like what you're seeing in the
political landscape
of america right like if you sleep with
women and then don't come back well
guess what that breeds that breeds to
the
f-boy movement where they're like all
the men i've been with
they you guys are participating in the
creation of that kind of idea
it's a circle right there is a middle
ground where you could just sleep with
people you do respect
and if you think someone's got too big
of an ego you will avoid them
no but but to me it's crazy bro
like i listen to some of this stuff and
i'm like i feel i feel like a lot of
people have listened to
a couple of youtube videos from certain
gurus and they've tried to assimilate
those ideas and they've done it
incorrectly
i think there's a lot of legitimate
ideas to some of the red pill community
but this guy's terrible at what he does
uh number four
tell her she's fat this is the number
oh this is the segment where you hear
the floor crack because i need to walk
this one off
tell her she's what okay
okay maybe the logic is because because
some women say a man is too short
that year four you should engage in the
same toxic behavior it's crazy bro
i think people love playing in the mud
that's what i'm starting to realize
they see they see some trash behavior
and their response to it's like i'm also
getting engaged in trash behavior if you
tell a woman she's fat
her whole life revolves around her image
how she looks yeah let's give people
eating disorders let's encourage
depression and stuff and all kinds of
people like look i
advocate against the idea when women say
stuff about men's height and they're
disrespectful
i always say it's wrong for women when
they're rejecting a dude to be outright
outlandishly mean for no reason but the
response to that is to not then you
therefore
saying all kinds of while to women as
well when you do that i question
your mindset like why would you go into
that behavior why are you trying to
breed other people who are hurt if it
was my siblings
or my family members and someone talked
to them that way and they were hurt
it would hurt me you know i mean you
can't just think of it as people outside
like these affect your communities
i just i don't understand this mindset
if you guys are just hanging out if she
has a girlfriend
tell her oh so-so looks kind of cute
katie shaquita or
i think i'm done with this video hey
bailey chum hey man you know what bailey
i'm glad you threatened us his argument
his argument his argument is that you
are using my contact without my
permission but i guess he doesn't know
what fair use constitutes
no this thing has been litigated in
court a couple times the problem is it's
too expensive for most youtubers
especially small ones
so people abuse the system to make sure
that they don't speak on any of this
stuff
but if you got the time to take it to
court and i got the time you feel me
because i got no bills to pay because
he's done it to smaller chances
absolutely and they can't afford to do
nothing
so he gave them strikes absolutely and
uh i don't think you realize it
and i hope one day you look back at some
of these videos these late couple years
down the line you recognize how toxic
you were being
there's no other way to put it yeah
that's tough listen you know on this
channel we we call women all the time on
some of the stuff that they say this is
the other end of that spectrum you know
what i'm saying
i think this is the reason why derek
jackson is in business because of dudes
like this
yeah no absolutely he's i i say to
people
he's married maxon no he's he's the
opposite he's the nemesis
he's a luke scott walker to to darth
sidious your sense of well-being should
not be predicated on the idea that you
put women down
should not be predicated on the idea
that it's your responsibility
to lower other people's self-esteem like
if you're doing all that kind of stuff
it's
it's gonna be terrible for you so i
don't recommend it i don't know your
life i don't know how it's been
but and i don't know what kind of
examples you had around you
but that's what you have to achieve
that's what you want to achieve that's
that's that's the main goal that's the
dynamics you want to go through life
with the person that you're being with
that's that dynamic that's what you want
to go about life
like this and not have maybe that's your
thing
bless your heart no they're red pilled
huh
they're woke the red pill man that's
nothing to do with that
you want to go in your house and be like
you know what and you want to graze your
kids like that
to be like that and in relationships
like that that that is normal
that is a normal way to talk to a human
being
so you don't respect them at all that is
disrespectful i don't respect women who
are on a pedestal
bless your heart amen i always say it
man
when you out there fight in the mud with
a pig to everyone who's watching you
look like just like a pig as well
and the thing is that you know what i'm
saying at some point you're going to
realize that the pig likes it
so if you guys want to be out there
being messy and adding drama to your
life go right ahead
go ahead honestly when i look at people
engaging in drama like that i think it
reflects poorly on them
when i talk to somebody and they're like
yeah i told ralph i told this i'm like
i look at you like what's wrong with you
that you are always in conflict like
this
you know like what are you doing to
bring this in your life where you're
fighting with people
when i see drama bro i'm trying to walk
away as fast as possible when some
girl's yelling at me in the street she's
going crazy
i'm not thinking i'm gonna put her her
head into the pavement or he said i'm
trying to be like yo can i get out of
this situation because this girl is wild
and i don't want to be involved with
this because i got responsibility so i
got things i gotta handle i got family
to take care of
you can't be bothered wasting my time
you got time for this ask yourself
don't you want to put your energy to
something more productive damn
what a waste of time bro what a way you
think you think successful people are
out here trying to put people's
pedestals down
bro you guys got time it's crazy
but anyways that's it for my advice uh i
don't subscribe to any of this kind of
thing
and if you guys think this is great
advice hey man
bless your heart
[Music]
foreign